okay glasses out so this is gonna be an
exciting okay fun cocktail little spoon
okay you put touch okay of sauce at the
bottom of the glass
yeah nothing worse and get into the
bottom of the prawn cocktail I slightly
dry so generous on the sauce then from
there take a little small teaspoon there
are my donk a quarter of an avocado in
each glass okay now just scoop that up
and you can see it all comes out a nice
little sort of dices huh Kelsey you're
very focused I'm impressed you know no I
know I know I know I know we this quiet
I don't I'm not normally this rapper but
I don't want get it wrong do I who's
looking great you know but again the
quarter in each one okay
got it man from there oh I've lost my
spell don'twe here we go here we are now
from there okay take your lettuce now
shred it beautifully I'm gonna put that
okay into the glass right Andrea time to
put the lettuce in how we do is looking
good
it's looking good stay with me yes huh
let us into the bus okay now from there
another tablespoon of sauce on top the
lettuce so we got sort of a card oh yeah
lettuce and sauce now and do assemblies
check to give away hot pants in the
seventies no no meaning the right cross
I swear to God
what's you that straight yeah right
prawns on top now be quite generous with
this okay right okay okay right Hong
Kong town we need a lot of prawns yeah
okay so source like sauce until the
lettuce that's of lesson between
slightly boring okay okay now from there
oh god you're way ahead of me slow down
ganya won't only ten seconds in front we
can't slow down here we go right spoon
on top of that and then from there okay
yeah pinch Achaean right okay finishes
off and makes it look pretty and then
finally our lemon now just a little
wedge okay for lemon wedge for sauce on
top of the producer on top of the prawns
yes okay well there we are
the most amazing 71 cocktail done